[Music]
the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia practices an
extreme interpretation of Islam that
imposes harsh curbs on women women must
live under the supervision of a male
guardian they need their Guardians
permission to get married divorced or
even set up a bank account and despite
the country having very limited public
transport women are not allowed to drive
but Manal al-sharif decided to take a
stand
miss al sharif worked for Saudi Arabia's
largest oil company in 2009 she was
posted to America one of the first
things she did was learn how to drive
when I Drive I feel liberated I feel I'm
independent and I feel free driving for
us is the same bull of resistance it's
all good if I needed all as a man to
drop my car I'm working and I saw I'm
still treated like a child
we're now returned to Saudi two years
later she was not prepared to give up
her newfound freedom someone had to lead
by example someone had to take their
action to show them that it can be done
this 2011 the Arab Spring was going on
and I saw the youth in Egypt using
social media Facebook YouTube and
Twitter to call for change we now use
social media to rally for a day of
action calling all Saudi women who could
drive to get in the car and take to the
roads
On June 17 were starting driving our own
cars by ourselves we call it drive your
own life
manal defiantly drove through the
streets of Kabul with a friend filming
live in Albania honey minute watch that
Orr McLaren fee nitesh hellish Tamiya of
the Kalama she posted the video on
YouTube it was viewed 700,000 times in
one day
but not all the attention Murnau
received was wanted Saudis secret police
came to her house she was arrested and
sentenced to nine days in prison there
was international law Reilly calling for
my release that led to my release my
father had to go actually to the king
and asked for a pardon my charges was
driving wild female
despite the threat of more prison time
she is still campaigning for women's
rights since driving in Saudi Arabia
manaus inspired others to get behind the
wheel in her home country as an act of
protest things are slowly changing in
May 2017 King Salman issued an order
allowing women to access education and
health care without the consent of a
male guardian
however guardianship is still extremely
limiting for women imagine you give
birth to own guardian because the
guardian can be the father the husband
if you don't have a man in your life
with an adult at Muharram it could be
your own son your own son gives you
permission to get your papers or leave
the country in this deeply conservative
Kingdom the fight for women's rights has
a long road ahead
[Music]